[Música]
vamos con las noticias de salud con más
Romero salamar Buen día para usted
Buenos días Ángela y también Buen día
para los hondureñas el gobierno levantó
un veto que pesaba sobre ellas de más de
10 años por la píldora del día después y
también conocida como la llamada
pastilla anticonceptiva de emergencia
hacía 10 años más de hecho desde 2009
que estaba prohibida Y ayer la
presidenta Xiomara Castro firmó una
orden a la que levantaba este veto es
uno de los países latinoamericanos con
leyes por ejemplo del aborto más
restrictivas en todo el continente y
donde no siempre además hay un acceso
fácil a métodos anticonceptivos por eso
puede ser una noticia tan importante
para muchas mujeres y para personas con
capacidad de gestar la pastilla se
prohibió bajo el pretexto de que provoca
abortos cosa que no es cierto ahora lo
explicaremos y uno de los compromisos de
Castro precisamente al llegar al
gobierno había sido revertir este veto
que se había impuesto hace más de 10
años en Honduras el aborto es ilegal en
todas las circunstancias incluso en los
casos de violación o de incesto puede
conllevar años de prisión y así tomar
relevancia no tener un método
anticonceptivo más vamos a ver el
anuncio de Xiomara Castro en el que
celebra además que eso sucederá eso
sucediera se firmó ayer no en el 8 de
marzo el día que se conmemoran los
derechos de las mujeres y explica
efectivamente no que no es abortiva lo
que hace es interrumpir o prevenir la
ovulación para que no pueda haber una
fecundación el día después de haber
tenido relaciones sexuales Pero en
ningún caso interrumpe un embarazo a una
fecundación que ya hubiera sucedido algo
que es importante tener en cuenta en
estos debates alrededor de la salud
sexual y reproductiva el contexto sexual
y reproductivo en Honduras es bien
complejo más cuéntanos sobre el tema si
tenemos algunas cifras porque es uno de
los países con mayor tasa de embarazo
adolescente también de toda América
Latina una de cuatro una de cada cuatro
chicas menores de 19 años ha estado
embarazada recogimos disfraz de unicef
también vemos que hasta 1,16% de las
adolescentes de 15 años han pasado por
un embarazo también esta cifra además se
va incrementando hasta que a los 19 años
hasta el 40% 4 de cada 10 jóvenes de 19
años han tenido un embarazo en el país
por supuesto Esto no es emitido desde un
lugar de juicio cualquier embarazo
consensuado con sentido después de la
mayoría de edad Debería ser un motivo de
celebración si la mujer lo ha decidido
Pero estas cifras suelen reflejar un
problema Por ejemplo en el acceso a la
información sobre métodos
anticonceptivos sobre salud sexual y
reproductiva en general y por supuesto
también nos habla de esa prohibición de
interrumpir el embarazo que lleva a
muchas jóvenes a llevar a términos
embarazos que no han sido deseados o
incluso acudir a abortos clandestinos
tenemos cifras también del centro de
derecho de mujeres de Honduras El aborto
clandestino El aborto inseguro
representó el 12% de las muertes
maternas en el país en los últimos años
una cifra y una tasa mucho más alta de
lo que suele ser habitual además
Honduras es el país con la mayor tasa de
feminicidio en la región y no se nos
olvide que esta es la última
consecuencia después de que otros
derechos Como los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos han sido violados mar
vamos a cambiar de tema para repasar un
estudio excepcional por su duración sí
son casi 8 décadas de seguimiento a más
de 3.500 personas es algo que es
normalmente difícil de ver no los
estudios suelen durar unos años pero
estamos hablando de casi 80 años para
revisar los efectos de las infecciones
respiratorias en la infancia a lo largo
de toda una vida empezó el estudio en
1946 en gales y en Inglaterra y terminó
en 2019 las conclusiones han publicado
en delante vamos con las principales
digamos titulares Y es que haber tenido
una infección respiratoria antes de los
dos años es decir por ejemplo una
bronquiolitis o una neumonía aumentaba
en un 93%, el riesgo de tener una muerte
prematura precisamente por una
enfermedad respiratorias decir que casi
dobla el riesgo estas infecciones en
edades tempranas podrían ser
responsables del 20% es decir una quinta
parte de las muertes prematuras por
enfermedades respiratorias entre los 26
y Los 73 años y si estas cifras se
extrapolan a la población de Inglaterra
y de gales donde se realizó el estudio
estamos hablando de que equivale a casi
180.000 muertes prematuras en todos los
años que duró el estudio es decir
estamos hablando de eso de varias
decenas de miles de muertes que se
pueden prevenir o que al menos ahora se
saben mejor se entienden mejor las
causas hay casos en los que los niños
pueden pasar por más de una infección
respiratoria Sí y eso también es una de
las conclusiones del estudio está
asociado también a un mayor riesgo vamos
a revisar un gráfico de probabilidad de
supervivencia vemos que desciende a
medida que pasan los años más
pausadamente en las personas que no
tuvieron ninguna infección en grave o
aguda antes de los dos años pero que a
medida que sumamos una infección dos
infecciones o tres infecciones y más la
probabilidad de supervivencia
especialmente a partir de los 40 años va
descendiendo además pues más
pronunciadamente y más rápidamente sobre
todo en los que tuvieron tres o más
infecciones los autores del estudio
aseguran que la correlación podría darse
porque las infecciones interrumpieron en
temprana edad interrumpieron el correcto
desarrollo de los pulmones o por qué
reflejaban que ya de entrada pues la
capacidad pulmonar los órganos de los
niños eran más débiles Y eso sigue
sucediendo a lo largo de los años por
supuesto hay otros factores que influyen
factores ambientales como la
contaminación o como fumar o como otros
factores de riesgo asociados a este tipo
de enfermedades pero esta información
que es muy valiosa por todos estos años
que ha durado puede servir para intentar
prevenir estas causas no estas
infecciones en los niños menores de 2
años por ejemplo Sabiendo si han tenido
una infección en los dos años intentar
optimizar su salud respiratoria en los
años siguientes evitando por ejemplo que
fume no intentando evitar estas
infecciones pues investigando en más
vacunas no entonces bueno tener esta
información
recolectado durante tantos años puede
servir para mejorar la salud a futuro
muy vital para los que paternan y las
que maternan gracias a usted mal Gracias
hasta mañana